hey guy helping are you seeing today
we're gonna be checking out some new
Nintendo switch accessories not secrets
that I'm obsessed with - has a switch
still yes I'm still obsessed I now
officially have beat Zelda I ended up
beating ganon on the plane and it was
kind of awkward because I had no one to
celebrate with I really did want to wait
until I was home to beat it but I
basically had five hours to kill on a
plane and I thought now all the time
let's check these out and you guys can
be on your way onto the next video after
it doesn't launch is that the first
thing that I wanted to show you was this
this is a handmade leather a Nintendo
switch bag made in San Francisco did I
mention handmade the place is called
water-filled SS bags calm so somebody
tweeted me saying that game over Greggy
recommended this and that I should get
it then I went and took a peek at the
bags oh look wow these are pretty
awesome they have a bunch of different
options and color combinations but this
is the one that I went with because I
feel like black is my favorite color so
it's got this really nice little zipper
back here so nice little mush so you can
put like some cords or really whatever
else you want to put in here I mean I
can actually fit my phone in there or
wallet I mean this could essentially be
a purse like I don't want straight guys
away from getting this but I mean this
is a nice clutch this is this looks good
they also give you some options at
accessories that you can get with it I'm
such a sucker for all of these clips
because I use these for everything I
clip them on my purse I use them when I
walk the dog I love being able to hook
tons of different things on so I think
this was um when you're at the checkout
it gives you the option to add these on
to your bag so these are the different
accessories that you could add on you
can add this clip you could have a lot
of strap or this matte black clip I
don't remember exactly what they were
called but you'll see on the website if
you decide to get this and that just
clips off just like so so it's got
places to put your game this right here
very nice although I plan on doing as
many all-digital games as possible so if
you gets the inside here there's a bunch
of different little pockets as well put
this in there fits like a glove it
actually fits quite well it's got these
little magnetic buttons here it's really
a good-looking bag and it's nice and
padded in here as well so I feel like
even if you put this inside
another bag or you do end up wearing it
sort of as a wristlet tightening it will
have some padding and protection and
it'll be little what are these these are
headphones so Nintendo sent me this to
backpack in this case to check out thank
you to never I appreciate it because I
have definitely bought way too many
Nintendo accessories for the switch
let's check these out these are Zelda
Kate's in chat earbud oh that's cute so
this has like the little area to put
your headphones in and you can wrap the
cable around there to keep them nice and
neat these look pretty good yeah pop
that in there okay I'm going to be
completely honest preceding this is
changing too much time I feel like I'm
never going to just scroll these up
again Wow super official next up is this
case my friend Joey actually had this
one I mean if this doesn't say hey i've
got an incentive switch in here i don't
know what does i do think i prefer
having a more subtle case so if you're
out and about and somebody sees if
they're not like I'm stealing that
that's an antenna switch in there this
time all kinds of accessories so we've
had some little bumpers that you can put
on your joy con talk about decked out
cut these little things that you can put
on your heads I don't know what those
are
oh that's napkin pretty quick I think
that the blue might look a lot better on
the Greyjoy Collins can you imagine
having white joy songs absolutely
beautiful you can look inside all it
comes with a nice protective cover panel
all this is good because the one that I
put on I did a very terrible job and
there's bubbles in it but looks like
this just has a little velcro spinning
attached which definitely have a little
bit of extra room there so be warned
I guess Linda place the joy had she felt
like it didn't fit perfectly whereas
some of the other cases do have a much
tighter fit but there is a lot more room
in here for pretty much anything
actually could probably put your switch
even in there
yeah look good I'm not quite sure with
beef or Foe I know what we promised the
controllers I mean that doesn't really
look good in this color combination I
mean if that's something you're into you
go for it now I am really been waiting
for is checking out this antenna switch
backpack even has a Nintendo switch logo
on it so on the front we've got this
nice little zipper opens up quite nicely
to have some more little zip places put
things bit places to put things
so inside the main bit pocket has two
other zippered areas put your items
let's look inside so here's one main
little pocket area what did I get my
laptop in here there's a lot of places -
pushing - oh wow this is overwhelming
a little another zipper up here cube to
put stuff in is crazy there is very
whole mini pocket like how many
controllers do they think that we're
gonna have there's one two three four
five six there's like six lock with joy
conven it's quite nice right there with
your pro controller there joy con slot
paper finally is super important for me
is will I be able to fit my laptop in it
let's see haven't had it sitting right
here oh yeah I mean there's so much room
look at that this is a 15-inch laptop
you put it here you can put it here
there's a lot of room in this thing a
lot more room than I thought almost
really well made zippered quite
responsive which is a great quality in
the zipper let me tell you because I
have had some backpacks that I bought
they were actually super expensive and I
was like this is a crap zipper what is
this I have not a single complaint about
this backpack if you were going to get
any of the things that I talked about
today this is it
this would be my number one favorite I
actually like this backpack way more
than my expensive handmade leather bags
mostly because I like to carry with me
absolutely everything and with this I
can with this it's basically just my
switch some little accessories and
things like that but I mean I can even
put my switch in here and then put it
wherever I'm wherever at once this is
nice
still like this would be an everyday bag
and then maybe if I'm going to like a
nice fancy red carpet or like a party
this would be my bag take those to
celebrate the launch of Mario Kart I'm
actually going to play some Velda right
now but after I play Zelda I'm gonna
play some Mario Kart this is kind of
like a three in one video we've got an
unboxing
we've got Delta gameplay and Mario Kart
so what better way to celebrate than
than this and I really haven't been
playing as much as I was before
thankfully because I was so obsessed and
disgusted with myself smells like you
gotta go outside you got to get videos
done you got to get work done you can't
be just sitting on the couch doing
nothing I wasn't doing nothing I would
save in high roll so where am I now I
don't know where I left off I still have
a lot of shrines to get sorry horsey if
I scared you
Mysterio is there any shrines over here
there's got to be something and you
stopped raining please have any special
over here it's got to be something over
your where's all the freaking tribes at
Keith oh my goodness well I'm just
walking around a lot
get away away away oh gosh
can it stop storming already of gusts up
the neckline get away from me get away
from it yes Bob leave me be Oh your fear
Gloria soreness damage he believed I
just I just died like trying to beat the
carbage guy your fears I haven't died in
this game in so long and that's how I go
out that's how I go out you're wasting
my time anyway okay we're going
somewhere else
because clearly this area sucks and I
hate it so where am i right now
Oh Tarrytown I think I was supposed to
do something let's go check in we'll see
how doing that was so close this town is
coming along nice really need homes 20
bundles of wood I think I have wood
we're not having afford it shoot I don't
have enough Wyatt okay mr. man I'll
better bring you some wood yeah I'll cut
the trees down on my own town cut only
two more okay well I use an extra scene
because I'm Nydia don't think I have one
I don't
that's absolutely master story why not
Wow
that was a beastly hit tonight I gave my
bathroom
guess what sir
now I've got enough wood for you yes yes
I have them to come soaked away get for
tailoring what where am I supposed to
find that person at let's go search for
somebody who can be tailor let me put on
a sexy lady outfit right me hello
call me get out here it's not your name
I need nothing from you
I need somebody whose last name is son
something son and by you
Jill where is something son oh there is
like a a pass code place over here that
I don't know it's half code is I'm going
to admit I'm cheating now look it up
here's the place I need a password for
GSC Dimond I'm cheating G f C Dimond
every time I've done that before it's
been wrong so I've had to wait until
like the next day and then I forget so I
was like there's no way I'm forgetting
about it this time we're going for it oh
look I don't think I have enough money
oh my gosh is there some cool stuff you
look at man
I'll give it trade the materials oh my
god
yes 800 rupees
give it to me this is beautiful
cheese now I got her you know what I was
actually doing it in the wrestling let
me write have fun thanks I'm beautiful
[Music]
come on I've got something for you I'm
so excited come on please please please
go to my town and that's it
Tarrytown my new princess okay let's go
see our on girl in Tarrytown
that's no no no I wanna go very too many
houses yet I gave you all my wood I give
you my wood in my promise live but I'm
looking at andagi
how's it going hmm did you more water
oh sorry bundle live oh dear goodness
gracious I'm gonna have to get to work
on that one
hey girl
look at this it's done mine look at your
beautiful rares no I don't want to sell
anything I wanted to say hi but I didn't
read what you said to me well that's
Tarrytown I didn't really accomplish
much in this episode I guess I'll go
finding some more wood or something but
I sorted in suit on toast mates so I'm
gonna go eat and then when I come back
it's gonna be just like that come on
play some Mario Kart we'll see you in
two seconds
are you ready done we're gonna play some
Mario I got a think up oh I don't know
who I want to be yo hey man we pink
Yoshi fun oh this looks fun Rainbow Room
Oh Carlo you're gonna shut nightmares
your babies really is but it's so fun
that scary at the same time
I'll stop crying I have a big
disadvantage because with the camera oh
okay good look scream like this that's
fine where's again everybody my goodness
I'm sense aw man this one's fun yeah
it's fun when we run in the right
direction
haha I like actually what nothing what's
wrong that's 1 in 700 I just got shot
all you know I'm in 7 I should get a
couple of warm-ups before it's late I'm
glad you did it cuz last time that's
what happened in you guys eat up
I don't think I did
whoever did it my mom goodness gracious
oh can we all get it I think you did the
place you're even now secondly oh yeah
that's okay I'm proud to be old should I
hit a nail I'm doing so bad
last lap a coin I coin is not going to
save me from these the quality rater you
a bit of a booth don't donate me until
Nicholas green there are young get just
so bad I need to get to the finish line
now
[Music]
if I had my phone I take a pic shoot
I've got first place I go first please
oh well I'm a bit okay that's not laughs
it's hot first it's not her as well gee
laughs Sarah
what if I'll go will the right direction
this time I mean I really cleared well
that Raceland backward you did I do it
every time
why that's wrong button everyone
why do anything that I do scheme no no
toilet program little bit better with my
turn
I'm getting dizzy oh hey bookshelves
myself oh but you what happened I got it
oh oh my okay well you know what would
you be a fire everything everything and
everyone you later again I'm in seventh
oh that was that wasn't me actually so
like a million people to hit me for
three oh my gosh I trying to go over
there it would let me why don't you not
let me do what I wanted to do so not
everything is not you Justine me ha I'm
getting nervous you I don't like to lose
things that I do quite often so it's
kind of like I'm fine with it cuz you
got to be okay with if you do it often
oh well I'm in first so you're in second
so now I'm not in first this is this is
tight this is a close race
my gosh Sparta do that why would I do
that
how do I do that why would I do that why
would I do that why would I do that why
not just to other things I just did not
even go in the right direction
I don't even know I feel like I was
going backwards and this is tough get
stuck
I'm not even on the track or Oh first
time I know man I know mariokart
mariokart logic unfair
IATA you're still you still above me no
I need to be the best let's look at that
map this is it's not sad is how
I remember this one contrast only about
easy there are so many freaking turn
yeah definitely to seeing them were sad
face it was a little game oh no no no my
acceleration is very what more what
where what a mana win it's hard
Oh was I'm going to cross my bra what
are we lazer lasers I don't know man oh
whoa later City oh my god I just got cut
okay I hit myself and then this is so
hard because I'm here he said go to my
way the bird did you guys fighting at
the rock I hit the rock a lot of people
it's a rock
one more lap a lot I mean in half a
while is true so much can happen
got lasers and what this alone well
everything is a setting right now for
one second
how do we do a rail this is so upsetting
that really is I feel like I'm tilting
my whole body so you are try to make a
bitter pill pill I'm like I've got a
Riesling first don't worry about what
I'm doing worry about yourself oh my god
everything is not awesome okay I was in
first second and now I'm turning around
and with six and one head of me I mean
I'm not God bro I think you're the
reason why everyone hates believing me
so tell me why will I fall off the mat
oh my god one minute like I still
remember it was intended to people um
that's a fun time
yeah life was good like a brand I was
small
you were you smaller yeah I was your new
baby
well I don't think I'm back yeah yeah
you were maybe I guess like I used to
actually sleep in your room so so Tajiks
are one of the TV for WoW then I hate a
patek why he didn't even get out I won't
play
I'm busy me too I'm upset I need a Jew I
need the rocket you can be a rocket I
haven't got that in a long time
[Applause]
[Music]
okay boys and blew myself up so I'm
gonna be it and then someone hit me oh
my goodness Oh
oh my gosh one more lap well I could get
Cuban roast bananas pnina pnina pnina
pnina pnina you know he scored a goal
tonight
good for him the one that made us win oh
yeah okay of course that book that is
the biggest bunch of crap that I've ever
seen what I was in first place and then
just all this stuff to came and hit me
at the last second yeah absolutely
welcome to my past upon sand bear this
game is such oh wait you bought for this
much what's gonna happen you won Oh what
oh my gosh look only buy one and we
didn't even place in the top three
sorry breathless arthritic fingers and
body well I think so much for watching
we had a fun time playing this man I'm
like losing my voice or two from yelling
I'm very upset I need to win I'll see
you guys later
hope you guys enjoy Mario Kart let me
know which President playing let me know
which think about the cases that I
showed you the beginning of this video I
finally unbox the missus actress oh so
nice it's incredible yeah I've been
looking at it here for a while oh I know
that was a while ago well see you guys
later bye bye Maddie
oh my
[Music]
you